really took his scoring average up a lot
so a lot of guys when they get the
opportunity they're not ready for it he
definitely was oh count the bucket
she's into it I'd love to see it
Miller I thought he was gonna go glass
he went straight for the rack that
wasn't tough
[Music]
I thought Charlotte got a steel bill I
really like him hello and hello Brandon
Miller speaking of things I like I like
Brandon Miller playing Above the Rim To
Know Your Role big fella but this right
here you see the fast break throw it up
Brandon Miller throwing it down
[Applause]
[Music]
that was really a big time get as well I
know the Dallas map was really hoping
that Portland wouldn't match that
offices we see Brandon Miller with the
three they get multiple first round
picks so they can continue to build on
the young court that they have that's
finding that that right oh
these are some of the things that fans
have been waiting to see from him right
there no wasted effort no wasted dribble
goes right down the lane
step back mcallenge leaves it well short
another opportunity though Miller steps
it back and right where that three-point
line was